hey guys welcome to the Evan and Kailyn
podcast make sure to stick around to the
end of today's episode cuz I'm about to
get murdered portion you are gonna
completely destroy me
because we are gonna be playing a
singing game where we try to hum along
with like nah not hum along with hum a
song and the other person has to guess
it's like that heads up game on your
phone you know cuz because I can't hum
so make sure to stick around for that
mess but the rest of the show we're
gonna have a little update on how we
almost lost our youtube channel which is
completely scary and a few other updates
and then we're gonna be talking about
like what our parents and family think
of our youtube career yep yep well let's
start with how we almost lost our
channel it's like it was kind of my
fault because I saw the email which I
wouldn't expect because you're typically
the more tech-savvy one of the two of us
I think that like okay so so I got an
email from in air quotes YouTube and it
was that a copyright claim was issued
for our channel and it was on our most
our most recent our second most recent
project and as i'd like click to view
claim details but everything was so
perfect it looked the exact same the
only thing that like would have thrown
me off as i've had have looked at like i
would have immediately realized if I
looked at who the sender was and it was
from like some not legitimate YouTube
account so that would have given it away
right away but the thing that saved me
I'm there are a few things that save me
one our contact email address on the
public side isn't the same as our behind
the scenes but I'm out saying which one
is which a lot of emails and then I
typed in the wrong password hilarious
yeah I was like I didn't send them the
correct password for any of the accounts
no just remembered the wrong password
yeah but like saved us by like things
could have gone so much more wrong it's
really scare
it was really scary like if they had
have sent it to the right email address
and I had it entered the correct
password for the correct email address
they could have like taken over our
account held it ransom deleted our
videos who knows what they would have
done but like I'm just thinking about
like our entire like career that we've
been working on for so long just having
the ability to like and I know that they
I know snap it and oh snap it I know
that that like people would find us even
if we had to start a new channel and
YouTube might be able to restore things
and it's everything but it's just still
incredibly scary and especially because
it was so close oh so close
and it was like it was crazy cuz it
wasn't a big deal till it was like I was
making lunch you were in the garage and
on your way in and you are like oh weird
we got a copyright claim and I was like
oh that's weird why don't you tacos yeah
let me just make it one more time
yeah and then you're like it's a did you
get it confirmation text to your home
does it get a confirmation text and I
was like never asks for a confirmation
task and I never got one either
we forgot tacos for a little bit
unfortunately we realize you typed in
the wrong class oh my gosh and it was
the wrong account yeah all these things
but but my gosh like the the one thing I
have to say is if you have a Google
account that has like important
information on it or really any account
turn on to step two step authentication
but also another thing the ID to be
careful of is if you turn on two step
authentication and it's tied to a cell
phone then that's also vulnerable
because people can steal like your cell
number from you via this like hack
called some swapping or something like
that later it was texting my number no
no no so so we we have authenticators on
our phone as one of the things so it's
like we have a digital app that gets
sends us texts which is one of the
security thing this and we also have a
Google Voice account that no one can
steal unless they steal our other Google
accounts
so it's just a scary scary world out
there and we had a moment of like it
existential panic it took us a bit to be
like are we okay like is everything fine
we're like checking all the accounts and
we're like can we should we eat tacos
now yeah I know perhaps we should like
move to like all random numbers where
every single password on every single
account is all randomized and we have
like a master account but see if that
had been the case you wouldn't have
tried to guess it you would have looked
it up I want to put on the right one my
mistakes and my forgetfulness is an
asset all right well one other thing
that I want to talk about try a little
new segment here we talked about like
industry news and just like discuss our
thoughts on it YouTube launched tiered
memberships yes and they've been pushing
their memberships for a while and I
think that they're trying to compete
with patreon and twitch at the same time
because you don't know who memberships
or I don't know what memberships are
it's basically like a patreon like
system except in the past it's just been
a single level tier I think five dollars
and you get a badge and whatever rewards
the Creator wants to give so that's what
memberships are yeah it's interesting
because I think that they're trying to
compete in a space where they're like
the big giant but at the same time these
smaller companies are able to be more
agile they're able to customize more
they're able to offer rich or features
yeah I mean there's still really big
companies but as I'm just clarifying so
it's like one thing that YouTube is
doing is you can like do private
community posts but I'm not sure what
features they have built in like how do
you send an email to all people of a
single tier can you collect their
addresses for physical rewards there's
all these things that these other
platforms all have built in and I'm all
for like giving people the choice to
support us on whatever platform they
want and everything but it's it's just
interesting because they're trying to
play the catch-up game in a way yeah
and then and then competing with twitch
you mean in terms of like super chats
and super chats but also it's like when
you're live chatting now on YouTube the
subscribers have like special badges on
them just like twitch so it's like
YouTube's kind of like looking over the
fence at its neighbors and saying Oh mmm
that's interesting let's try that over
here what do you think they're gonna try
next I think that they're just gonna try
to eat up everything I mean they keep on
trying these things like like oh man the
poor like Google+ profiles trying to
compete with Facebook that was Google+
that wasn't YouTube yeah but I mean like
that's Google's philosophy in general
the goodness I try to gobble things up
and then they're like oh that didn't
work let's just cancel do you know like
people still enjoy it like Google
Hangouts why that why are they cancel in
Google Hangouts what are you doing well
I'm not gonna be sad about it until it
happens because something here still
here yeah YouTube also tried to do
stories like Instagram yeah Wow I had
that for a while which I stopped
completely yeah I mean we also don't do
stories I wonder like in terms of other
things that they could do one that I
think would be interesting maybe they do
this cuz so like YouTube has hashtags
there is a hashtag system but I wish
that you could like subscribe or I just
think it'd be cool if you could
subscribe to a hashtag the same way
Instagram you know they had hashtags
before him but more recently and I'm not
like up on the Instagram news but more
recently then hashtags were developed
they also started where you can follow a
hashtag yeah so it shows up in your news
feed and I think it'd be interesting if
YouTube did the same thing because let's
say follow the hashtag hashtag on
YouTube for a while yeah especially when
it's like around event stuff and you
don't really know who to search for
necessarily you just want to see stuff
about that event yeah and then like you
know you you the popular ones are the
ones that are gaining the traction of
that hashtag that have like prove that
it's the correct open your feed and
everything just like you would for like
but then at the same time it's like cool
YouTube kind of does that if you search
for Ally
a topic again and again in your watch
and all these videos and YouTube's
pushing them in your face but then you
can't unsubscribe from them afterwards
yeah because that's not a subscription
that's just you do algorithm trying to
guess and you watch one video on one
subject and it's like oh you like that
how about this yeah but I do think you'd
be interesting if you could like follow
and unfollow hashtags let's go let's
call up Susan yeah I know it's like it's
like 10 p.m. there but you know maybe
she works the hours that we work who
knows another quick update I mean this
is something that we've I think maybe
mentioned before but we're back in the
like hunt for editors for our gaming
videos I think we mentioned it recently
because we had some comments about it oh
maybe we already talked about this
finding editors is hard finding editors
is hard sometimes forget all the places
we talked about things like do we talked
about it in an interview did we talk
about it to each other or to you mean
like me no no I'm not a co-worker it's
like I kind of think of like if we
chatted with Bob he's kind of like a
co-worker like other youtubers work
acquaintances or like you know fellow
creators people who are like friends
with yes but like fellow creators also
sounds too pointy toidy hoity-toity
friends I say other youtubers other
youtubers yeah even though that word has
like a stigma too but also it's like
they're more than just other youtubers
to us they're like YouTube friends are
you two friends yeah yeah anyway so
let's get into the speaking of YouTube
and YouTube has a career let's get into
what our parents thought of it when we
like we're first getting into YouTube
this is a question asked by Tim
Morrissey so thank you Tim for the
question I think that everything has
gone in stage
because there is like the stage or we
are thinking about it there's a stage
when we were going for it where we were
like hustling and there's a lot of work
and then when we made it I think that
the very beginning it as in like went
full-time yeah like yeah like we had
proven that it was the right decision to
do I think that in the beginning it's
hard to say how serious you are about
something when it hasn't really happened
for you yet you know like when we were
first getting into you dude we were like
oh we're gonna try out this thing you
know I don't know I think that we were
pretty honest with their parents the
whole process but in the beginning we
also didn't want to get our own hopes up
so I think that feel like I kind of went
in I feel like from the beginning I was
I wasn't hedging my bets really mm-hmm
yeah it was like not that I was like oh
we're totally gonna make it it was just
like I had to have the mindset that were
if we're working this hard I think that
when I when I was first telling my
parents and family about it I think I
might have hedged my expectation bets on
there and a little bit did you just tell
your parents like hey guys we're gonna
start doing this YouTube career I mean I
think I might have softened it a little
bit but not not really softened it but I
like logic through it mmm it was like we
decided to try your hand at starting a
channel we know it's gonna be a lot of
work and we're just gonna build it up
nights and weekends and you know if it
proves to be successful enough we'll
start cutting back on our day jobs and
we can always get another job if we can
quit and it doesn't work out but it was
still very much like we're doing this to
do this you know yeah I think that I
mean at that point I was self-employed
and I was doing contract work and I had
like a lot of flexibility so I think
that when I when I told my parents about
it I'm not sure how seriously they
thought we were about YouTube
because at the same time I was doing my
own freelancing and like I was very
fluid state of like finding myself and
finding what I'm gonna do
life and stuff that like a corporate
eight-to-five yeah I know my mom was
definitely like slightly very concerned
sliced very concerned about like our
finances and our health care and like
what we were gonna do about all these
other things because I that time you
were providing the health care for both
of us and my mom was like well if you
quit like what how are you gonna get
your health care and like what about
like financial stability and all these
things I think that she was really
concerned but I know your parents
weren't worried at all cuz like you are
a planner and you have a plan and your
parents kind of know if you're doing
something you've thought it all the way
through so they kind of trust you not
that my parents don't trust me but I am
a little bit more flighty not flighty
five years in three-word a little bit
more like easily distracted yes lose I
mean yeah or like you'll be really into
something but then you won't finish it
have to both of those are true things so
I think that maybe my parents were a
little bit concerned about that and I
did have a good consulting gig going and
a lot of flexibility and stuff so
they're like you already like quit the
job that you that was like draining the
life out of you you have something good
here like that most people would that's
that's interesting because you had
already like upgraded your job situation
from like the life draining like
full-time to the more flexible
consulting but also I think that one
thing that I think I was thinking
long-term too is I'd seen you go through
the freelance and consulting route and I
know that sometimes things are really
good and kind of consistent and
sometimes there's dry spells and stuff
and if you have those long-term clients
it's like a little bit of feast and
famine sometimes there's too much but
sometimes it's too little and you can't
really like fully control that and
everything and I didn't want that for my
like long-term life moving forward and I
thought like if we build our own thing
that we are fully in control of we can
adjust it and I know that is we're
having a really hard time turning that
dial down right now
yes but we turn it up as high as we want
we can up as high as we want
that's so morbid if we can turn it up as
high as we want but we do have a hard
time turning it down I mean we've gone
into all the reasons we don't need to
rehash that but I think that you know
both of our parents were were very
supportive yeah and nobody no one like
it was like this is dumb no one ever
said this is dumb
some there was some like potential like
warnings about jumping in too fast
yes yeah there is one one one in
particular what am I more distant family
members she goes can like well maybe you
can just wait until you think it's too
late and then just don't do it that's
good advice don't quit your day job work
around well I think that also like
depending on people's age and what
they've been exposed to with YouTube and
and all of that there's there's not a
full understanding of this and you know
there aren't that there aren't any
people in the world that have made an
entire life's career out of you know
YouTube from when you finish high school
or college until you retire so there is
no like I'm just gonna do what this
person did you know I mean everyone is
still in flux and you know there are a
lot of ups and downs in this field in
general you know isn't it weird to think
that there's like classes now college
classes on content creation it's really
weird it's so weird well but also it'd
be so hard to teach this because I mean
there's there's so you can help people
practice and you can help people like
develop some skills with like technical
skills like like you can you can do like
here's how Photoshop works and premiere
works and here is you know general
theory on thumbnails but I mean like you
know the theory on what works on
thumbnails will change semester this
semester
you know I mean it's and also like genre
to genre like what works for travel
vlogs than what works for a DI
and what works for you no personality
based DIY vers woodworking DIY verse
crafty DIY I mean everything is
completely different and you could like
provide a space for you know
experimentation and feedback and all of
that in the classroom setting but yeah
oh my god should be so hard to teach
yeah but so one interesting thing this
is going back to what you're saying
earlier is I do think for like our
parents and aunts and uncles and like
the family members that are older than
us it was maybe a little like weirder to
wrap their heads around but for our
younger cousins how are you gonna
monetize hey can you sponsor show you
gives you Adsense oh yeah that's really
cool just make sure you don't get you
monetize my yeah yeah yeah how many subs
her yeah and he told him in there oh
yeah that's good that's good yeah that's
like no one else knew yeah like they
totally know all of the words and
Thaksin oh yeah
some of some of our younger cousins it's
a hard some of our shop Hava Nagila comm
some of our younger cousins they like
all over the entertainment they don't
watch TV they don't watch it as many
movies anymore like they just are
excited about Shane Dawson's new release
and and you know they keep up with all
of these like you know personalities on
YouTube and everything and that's fast
entertainment and that's like their
whole thing which is completely
different I mean that's how it is for us
but I mean we watch a couple things on
Netflix we're super behind right very
mr. need to start the new station things
and Rick and Morty we're bossy isn't it
out yeah what let me Google crack it's
November what season have we seen have
we seen season three I don't know how
many we've seen all of them really
unless a new one is out oh we have we
have seen yeah we've seen season three
okay so so never
completely lied season four is coming
out in November November isn't that far
away yeah we got very distracted there
yeah yeah I think like generally our our
family's pretty open to it it's
interesting because I've heard it I feel
like I've heard a lot of stories where
people started their channels and didn't
tell anyone like didn't know family
didn't tell friends it was like we told
literally everybody we told our family
our friends our co-workers everybody
everybody yeah and and everyone was
pretty supportive at the same time not
all of them knew what it was yeah when I
did feel kind of weird like like telling
my co-workers was kind of weird in the
beginning it wasn't really because it
was like doing this thing and then like
as we started getting more and more
serious like I'd have coworkers that
were like keeping an eye on on like our
subs so we'd have people like oh you're
at 30k now yeah so as we're cuz like the
farther along we got you know and like
the more exciting news we had the closer
we were to quitting yeah I think that
now that we've made it it's really easy
for everyone to understand it and accept
it yeah less sure about how we were
gonna actually make money yeah so it's
like yeah once we've proven ourselves
that were capable of this and that we
you know I mean obviously now that we're
here everyone kind of accepts it but I
think don't think everyone fully
understands it they don't understand it
but they're like cool like oh cool yeah
but no one's convincing us not to do it
if you yeah yeah I mean you know we do
get the usual questions that we've
already answered and everything but yeah
how do you make money and like what's
your tyrunt plan and do you pay for your
own health insurance yes
still working on the retirement plan we
submitted some forms today we disarmed
responsible adult stop yeah but I also
get asked a lot actually and not just by
family but people wonder like how we
work together oh yeah you know we talked
about that too but I think that's
another kind of like mystery to some
people yeah I mean you know I think that
you know as we continue to develop our
channel develop our style all of that
like I think that it'll just continue
get it easier I think that every time
we've done like an evident Caitlyn
saddest channel update we're always like
we're figuring things out I think we're
almost done figuring things out and like
right now hey we're figuring more things
our we've almost figured things out
[Laughter]
maybe I think that once we have like
maybe one or two like formulas that we
can kind of follow like like I mean like
series once you have a few series and
stuff maybe they give us head up yeah
the thing is I don't think we're ever
gonna be static at the other thing is
like as soon as you figure out one thing
you like introduce a new variable mm-hmm
true true but I think that like what we
figured out about lighting and cameras
and what we will soon figure out about
audio will last us a long time that
you're talking about like the channel
itself
oh well that that too like there's a lot
of pain points that oh like they're
working together there are some things
that like we do kind of like go down
rabbit holes and we just want it to be
done and like we never get upset at each
other but there are some times we're
like we are struggling with something
together and we're like just want to be
done with it just like everyone else and
just look like normal
that's true oh there's another thing
that we we had a moment while we were
filming our latest episode which won't
be out when this comes out and I think
refused it the soap episode coming up
yeah they know
so we
we were doing the intro and we had a lot
we had a hard hard time with that we did
a really good first take we lost the
audio we'll talk about it more in the
after show for that but it was it was
tough and all of the things afterwards
we were just having such a hard time
getting all of the words and making a
genuine and all of that stuff hope it
takes afterwards all of the takes and I
think that one thing we talked about
afterwards when we were like analyzing
why it was so hard and just thinking
about you know that situation and if
there's any learning moments we could
take from that I think that one thing I
realized is if we had have been normal
co-workers not not married I think that
we would have just called it good a lot
earlier we have been like sure that was
fine like we would have been more
encouraging but not as real with each
other yeah we would have liked it would
have maybe we may not have let ourselves
get that frustrated like when you're
with co-workers you just try to like
continue to be happy and like you know
push through things and you don't like
acknowledge how tough for hard things
are but I think that because we could
have that honesty with each other like
that wasn't the best take let's do that
again again and again and again but like
so in a way it was I think more painful
because we just didn't like shrug it off
and move on it was a lot better we ended
up with a better product yeah because we
can be real with each other we're like
yeah that wasn't good work yeah I think
we're more critical of ourselves and I
think there's a little bit of that
honesty too cuz like yeah it'd be
embarrassing to say like man that sucked
I didn't feel that let's do it again and
again and again and again after a while
I just get embarrassed about it you'd
say like sure I feel good about that one
even though internally you're just like
completely cringing yeah well that was a
little bit of a side tangent to we're
just having a lot of side tangents today
it's probably because it's 11 p.m. it is
11 p.m. but it's time to record the
podcast it was on our to-do list they're
sticking with it when we're knocking it
down or making progress on our like you
know what we're trying to like this is
the in air quotes by for a week
and you know we have a long video we
filmed we're a little bit behind on that
so we really needed this week anyways
but I you know we're also during this
week when something comes up we like
take it and our to do this is going down
a lot of those long term to dues are
like getting shrugged off our shoulder
and it feels so great for weeks it's
been building up still in a minute an
amazing idea
we need more thoughts on what our
parents and family think about our
YouTube thing I mean it's it's you know
because everyone's so supportive it's
not the most exciting thing to tell what
everyone's been really cool yeah yeah
it's it's fun I will say I think the
person that has the most insight into
like all the work is probably my mom
because there's been a couple times
they're like dad had to travel for work
so she was like oh let's come visit Evan
in Caitlin and so she came in would stay
at her house for a few days and you know
we still have to keep filming and stuff
and so she would be here while we were
you know recording a podcast or filming
or just having the email day or having
an edit day trying to figure out trying
to figure out how to hire editors or
yeah we were like when we were doing our
first round of gaming editor hiring we
were like showing her all the yet it's
you know and she was helping us choose
and so I think she probably has the like
clearest view of what the day-to-day is
like and all the extra stuff that isn't
just you know what you see in the video
which honestly is just you know you wake
up and you work and you eat meals and
you go to bed I mean when she was here
she was really flexible she just like
ate meals with us and just let us be
[Music]
and she's still addicted to some of them
or she still watches some of them which
is awesome speaking of no no I'll say
that's my thing right
oh no but speaking of track guys we're
gonna see them live oh you're their toy
oh yeah took the tour in two days well
do days from now by the time this comes
out it will have been yesterday yeah so
I'll be really exciting well tell you
guys how it is I'm so excited it's just
so interesting to see you know people in
the same industry as us doing
the things that they're doing they wrote
a book it was a New York Times
bestseller they're on all those like
talk shows they did the the shenanigans
in New York they're like doing this like
multi-state super city pyrotechnic like
crazy to her event and it's just it's
just really cool to see what like what
you can do when you're pursuing your
passions if you have a passion for
something like this can help you this
can help boost it up you know I mean
yeah it's super exciting I'm I cannot
wait I'm really excited
I've been trying to like not listen to
their podcast episodes where they talk
about the show to give anything away I
started wondering I was like oh they're
talking too much about it it's great
because I was able to listen to it and
I've already forgotten so it's still
gonna do surprise speaking of you
forgetting things do you want to play
the game yes it's game time
so I'm gonna cheat and I'm gonna put in
this headphone right here
so that I can like I have a playlist on
my phone and if I need some help
remembering how a song goes I think you
should try it without it first and then
okay okay so so the game is another like
guest that song type of game but the
rule is you can only hum the song you
can like hum or do you like dead uh does
you know you but you can't use any of
the words and the other person has to
guess it best on your humming so you
guys get to hear our lovely voices and
we have a partial point system to to put
in place put in place as a pity to me so
if you can sing the song like you
recognize that you sing it you get a
half point if you know the artist you
get another half point but if you know
all of that and you can actually name
the actual song don't combine it if you
can name the song that's a full point is
a half and being able to hum along with
the song is a half point so you have the
option to get to full point two full
points potentially yeah okay you ready
yeah or how are we gonna keep score
digitally afterwards we were it'll be a
surprise to us so so I'm gonna start off
and I'm gonna vial
one of our rules we said that we weren't
going to sing the song only the lyrics
violator right away I just have to do it
this way okay I have a tiger yes
I don't know the artist it's from the
Rocky movie so I have the tiger from
Rocky movie you can probably hum it see
you're at one and a half point if
someone can guess the song they can have
it yes but you don't know the artist 1/2
points ok I'll take it the artist
survivor that rip that's the artist
that's artists did you know that I know
it now I might have been able to get it
test me test me doing yours okay I will
say you chose a pretty easy one for me I
get harder it's too hard though farmers
are really hard Danna dananananana
Barbie world yeah I'm guessing
everywhere nice antastic when you're
plastic it's not Barbie Orkin jumble
things like the jungle time jungle
sounds jungle jungle Jane what are you
serious
two different bands it's higher than
words like long hair long hair
knock off the end okay I only get one
half points - okay it's aqua oh yeah I
was about to say that
okay
[Music]
okay my heart will go on Celine Dion dad
dad dad dad call me maybe by Carly Rae
Jepsen accounts you violated yeah like
yeah I get a get two points I get the
two points I'm making a judgment call
here because I still think I'm gonna
beat you so it's a pity I gotta go now
[Music]
okay I'm Charlie get to the lyrics in my
head cuz I'm not listening to the
secular
[Music]
[Laughter]
funky music til I die I mean play that
funky music
that's the name of this well actually
I mean your print you play that funky
music oh my god
I'm a genius at first you started at
funky lady so I have I have two points
everyone laughs yeah new who the artists
I don't neither the funky lady band okay
okay ready for a hard one yeah you're
gonna know the song but you won't know
the artist I don't think
[Music]
mmm-hmm keep going just memorize to -
hums oh yeah you got it
I thought that'd be hard one good I
should get points for that basically I
[Music]
know I know you know that song could you
hummed it I love the song I listen to
song I like this I think like I know I
know that's wrong right
I mean there's only one time for that
music in all cities there's not one like
all rock station still play the same
songs from high school or high school
like oh gosh I don't even want to know
think about how long ago that was by the
Zartha no there's no way in it it starts
with P it's two words - want me to give
you a clue no it's a PD ho there's a P
the P and there's no I know in the
second warhead okay you want a clue a
clue
father bug Papa Roach
[Laughter]
yeah yeah wasn't one of my most
frequently listened to song so still
totally know it dad dad
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh because I'm happy yeah you are you
see I gotta take you so long my singing
was totally damn out that good bonus
points okay done Dana Nana nanana nanana
nananana
[Music]
no no yeah that's the band name their
songs after any lyrics yeah it's just
like a name Bob sphere moon son Jimmy
Jones James I write sins not tragedies
of course of course
all right no tragedies like I think
songs like this and disco disco and I
write sells out tragedies exactly okay
you haven't
I've been choosing two easy ones because
I think like what are the things that
gets stuck in your head that I might be
able to hum have any chance of humming I
know but I only started this halfway
through I should have thought of like
the cheating earlier games normally go
the first time around dad dad dad dad
stop
on your first note I thought you're
doing rocking again cuz use go death
stop stop in the name of love bye I
don't know
come on The Supremes how could you
forget there's a halfway there no 1/2
points we are both pretty bad at
definite card all right you're doing
also remember that we you can do an
obscure part of the song to make it more
difficult we can only give them so much
singing in one episode here you can't
you can't make me laugh I'm making you
laugh you challenged me to do it it's
part of it
[Music]
[Music]
I know it I get a half line for that
[Laughter]
it's like the band that you never know
what they're saying it's just like the
actual lyrics I was saying do the UM not
of course the of the verse it's like um
Creed but Oh like uh you said it's like
um Creed it's like uh it's like a cute
boy you got one more word then you guess
the song it's like a dream no it's like
a it's like a stream chocolatey it's
like I got like it like it down like a
dog like it's like a deer
[Laughter]
do you know the artist it's not
Audioslave keep it not yeah they start
with an A it's like two words put
together
[Music]
hmm yes it's like a stone by Audioslave
I have all easy things here yeah I've
gotten all of yours you can give me like
a hard part of the song bye I want to
sing the good part well then you can't
get to the good part after if I don't
get it or you can say I think they're
trying to trying to hum along with it
like try to transcribe wall I listen to
it it's harder a little bit and then do
it okay Kylie there's a really easy part
that'll give it away I'm kind of dude in
the middle would recognize me do you
understand what you're hearing is it too
much
[Music]
I was gonna sing the beginning just like
that but only part I know evidently I
skate for and I'm like I don't recognize
this is it muse dan dan dan dan de baby
or could we under pressure I'm gonna say
under pressure okay
yeah I'm trying to say like the middle
of it I'm like oh how there's so much
going on here
oh yeah it's like fast yeah there's like
so much going on there's like there's
high pitch songs and they're singing all
these words and I'm like oh jeez
there was like a skip up but I'm just
gonna part part in it I don't remember
and I'm running out of anything that
might be hard yeah
[Music]
Sally song for [ __ ] I got it I got a
debt off really easy two points all
right let me do I mean to my last one
that might be potentially hard okay you
can also just like I think just make one
up randomly the most analyzed by the Bee
Gees cutting two points okay I got a few
more for you alright dad
that
duh
nananana
[Music]
[Music]
make it halfway something makes the
world go round
I'll give you a clue yes you did a song
by this artist you're right there is the
words makes the world go round not
there's another word in that in between
some of those words I could sing some of
the words yeah I was just a skinny lad
never knew how good from bad know just
listening I was like nodding and it's
doing the and more gesture know
something makes the world go around rock
paper scissors no and that's not the
title it's just like a work part of the
lyrics in the beginning mmm the
beginning okay banana
[Music]
I basically wrote the tack for you I
just knew it by heart the second time
around its side observe I at least okay
yeah because you're not cream yeah well
like rock bottom boys boys bottom flat
bottom so shoes make their Felger flat
bottom Jews made the world go down so I
I get one whole point here I'm up to one
point yes sadly somehow can you get that
last point what's not boys but man he
was a boy she was a girl okay
five bottom girls full bottom two girls
bottom girls five bottom girls yeah yeah
yeah is it full
no is it flat bottom holy sit flat and
then just full bottoms ladies who make
the world cover five bottom girls by
Queens two points two points let's shake
on it
two points for effort making me laugh
yes okay you got any more I got I got a
couple more I got one more and then I
think that's called
is it because it's like yeah oh boy I
just chose like big artists and like
things that most everyone knows cuz I
thought that'd be good for guessing too
but I think it was made it too easy yeah
I mean I think it's good to find ones
that like the audience can guess with
but like I may not know I summed you
keep going
[Music]
I want to hold your hand I was too good
I just outdid myself I'll try to throw
you off like you know Punk you oh yeah
that's one she's a good one
I am I'm trying to choose one that's a
good balance I mean who knows tender and
and enter dan dan dan dan dan dan dan
dan dan dan dan dan dan dan dan dan dan
dan dan dan dan dan dan I'm Anna
nananana dan dan dan and uh dananana
yeah take your booty yeah
yeah dan Ted - Dan - Lady Marmalade
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you again
shake your booty yeah on the party yeah
I know it now hey go do the court do you
like the main part do the boys
Backstreet Boys I got to the back
streets backstreet's back tonight back
sweet that factories that what everybody
parenthesis backstreet's back two points
[Music]
after the beginning of that one I'm
surprised you got there
so that's like basically call it ty I
mean who needs to the points anyways
right I think that like as the score
denotes right here it's basically a tie
okay moving on
think of the week
[Music]
okay so my thing of the week we were
speaking of charlie guys earlier and my
pic of the week is actually try guys
there's a try guys DIY where it's
basically Ned and his wife and they're
like helping their friends renovate
their homes and turn their like spaces
in the more livable workable spaces and
it's kind of like it's like HGTV boat
with cursing and people that we already
care about them you care about but also
like I was just laughing cuz it was like
HGTV but like dirty jokes and everything
yeah yeah there's a lot of great humor
in there and it's just genuine and it's
interesting to see like a TV format
that's been done so much done in YouTube
instead by a crew that could that could
take that on you know what I mean yeah
because they do have a big enough crew
that they could do that type of
production but also it still has like
the rock more broadness yeah but still
had like some like little TV like
effects like the little graphics and
overlays and like planning and like the
roll like good editing and stuff but
it's like an interesting mix of two
different genres and platforms and
there's this a lot going on there so I
think it's just an interesting video
what is entertaining for anyone who
wants to entertaining content but also I
think it's like a really interesting an
example of a lot of thing that's going
on and kind of like what there might be
in the future of certain channels and
certain content and stuff like that it's
just this is very interesting
it's very interesting um my pick is also
a YouTube video um as you guys know from
my last pick we've been watching a lot
of soap making videos but we've also
been watching a lot of Sofia Nygaard
lately and she attempted a soap making
video a new legit so - the ones like
that [ __ ] like really difficult kind she
followed a tutorial and it was super
entertaining to watch I won't say I
won't say the details of what happened
but like the attempt the the type she
attempted to make is like if you don't
do it right there can be explosions and
things can be corroded and like things
may have gone wrong there's no just
crazy reactions that can happen and so
it was really interesting I also like
the way that she like does her videos
cuz she's kind of like scientific with
her presentation
yeah you know she sets things up really
well she does a good analysis afterwards
she's old and stuff yeah videos are
super entertaining but like the
structure of them very she ate it yeah
yeah it's like she puts a lot of time
and effort into like the structure so
yeah we've been watching a lot of her
videos recently we have it's nice to
find another channel we're like I just
know that Oh like I'm gonna enjoy all of
these yeah like she known about her
channel for awhile I just hadn't watched
it yet I think sometimes like it takes
you a little bit to get used to a
person's style and know that that's them
you know it's like when you first watch
someone you may think that they're
trying to be something or whatever but
then like after you watch a few you're
just like oh that's just who they are
and how they make videos and it's
natural and everything is good here you
know what I mean I don't know I think
that we might like like know when they
come to our Channel and we're like you
know what people might be like whoa
these guys they're just trying too hard
or they're trying the cringe but like
that's us you know what we are us and
that is our truth so deep if you like
our deep thoughts on life and stuff you
know you can leave in a pit your opinion
in a five star review on iTunes
nice transition we just completed others
words don't we yeah so good
okay guys what completing each other's
words being like I start half of a word
and you finish the word yes transition
see ya good job it's like there's a mind
to mind the connection here it's like
bluetooth but it's like brand yes I was
about to say the same thing
you know what Kailen that blew my
ah that's what we're gonna end it
alright guys thanks for tuning in we'll
look forward to seeing you next time
[Music]